I said it earlier like, I'm a little bit surprised...
...and very grateful just to be in the mix with players.
They were nominated and all of those players had great seasons.
So yeah, I'm a little bit surprised but to win it back-to-back...
You know, I'm hugely grateful just to be...
...part of an awesome All Blacks team...
...because I'm only a small part of that team...
...and here I am, getting the credit for it.
It's been a challenging year for us...
...more than one way, one of injuries, and also being tested on the field...
We saw that in the line series...
...and you know, we've learned so much from there,...
...which is great and we'll sort of take that into the next couple of years,...
...getting to the World Cup.
We know that we have to keep finding ways to improve...
...and I guess develop our game so it's less predictable at times.
So, that's exciting because we've got great talent and a great team culture...
...but the game of rugby is always changing.